the pandemic is dramatically changing
our everyday lives including how we work
how we socialize and even how we date in
our series on the new normal
Jamie yuccas has been talking to people
practicing social distancing while
looking for love Jamie good morning I
guess this is look but do not touch time
how are people working this out that's a
good way to put it Tony Singles are
finding ways to emotionally connect
through the computer screen dating apps
of course are asking people to virtually
chat versus meeting up in person right
now but there are some couples who are
getting very creative love really is in
the air in New York City last month
Jeremy Cohen turned to his drone to get
the attention of Tori Cigna Ella after
he spotted her dancing on her buildings
rooftop across the street I went out to
my balcony and I said hi and she waved
back and said hi I kind of said
something along the lines of like I'm
gonna send you something and then I
wrote my number on my drone and then I
ran up to the roof since then there's
been a rooftop dinner a second date in
person with Cohen in a protective bubble
and a special romantic gesture for
Tori's birthday courtesy of an
old-school boombox obviously this bond
just over this crazy scenario but we
also get along really well as just like
humans and individuals which has been
really nice to actually focus on many
Americans have been told to stay home to
stop the spread of coronavirus some
people like Jamie Shapiro are embracing
the change the single mom of three is
using her new free time to FaceTime
Facebook and a lot of people are saying
I'm not gonna date right now because
can't meet what's the point I'm like
this is the point this is the time so
far she's met several potential matches
but she's also facing the same
frustration some experience in real life
including getting stood up I put makeup
on like you know and then he didn't show
and it was actually kind of man like I
just like put on lipstick for you
think it's the first time in a lot of
people's life where they felt just
prevented from contact with others
Daniel Jones is the editor of the New
York Times column modern love do you
have advice for people that might want
to go down this road
I think inhibitions are falling can fall
away and you can ask the deep questions
and learn about their past and learn
about their fears and learn about their
hopes for the future and now dating apps
like bumble and tinder are pushing users
to video chat instead bumble says video
chats increased 56% in late March and
those video dates are lasting on average
more than 20 minutes do you think that
you could get interested in someone over
video and and be in it for a while until
you can meet each other I mean aren't
there movies about this stuff like
there's it's it's possible it really is
it's kind of like a pen pal you know
after a while I like a video pen pal and
then after at some point you're like
doing here
so look you you could possibly find
lasting love I'm an optimist hey I'm a
careful optimist everyone once a
Hollywood ending right well according to
dating com only 5% of users say they
will not date during isolation whereas
82% say Tony that they still hope to
find lasting love by dating online I can
understand why Jamie I mean there's a
real sweetness to this when you have
communication you have the video
chatting but no potential for anything
beyond that it allows people to just
focus on the basics joy like this person
are they funny are they interesting but
I understand a little birdie told me
that maybe you've been out there trying
the dating apps in the era of the
pandemic how's that been going
I I was not gonna do it in this story I
thought I'll do some research and see if
it actually does turn out to be true I
went on three zoom dates after texting
calling then you move up to the zoom and
I have to tell you I've met some
that I'm really having fun getting to
know and it is as you said it's sweet
and it's it's a little old-fashioned
which has been nice but we've been very
respectful fashion walk oh that's lovely
it is very old-fashioned it feels like I
returned it like the Victorian air right
here I hope you're wearing a big frilly
white dress and carrying a parasol on
your walk
but that's lovely game I'm glad to hear
it and I hope that that person is
watching if they didn't know that you
like them they know now